what's up everybody welcome back to
another episode of the corridor cast I'm
here with Addie Shankar who has joined
me multiple times in the past we've
talked about the world for creators the
world of art the world of film personal
Endeavors so many sketchy Behavior just
general sketchy behavior and how we can
leverage it to
improve yeah to improve but you're like
so if I if I were to sum sum up like my
vision of you for as a as an industry
member like not as not as like a
personal friend but just like as a guy
in the industry i' would sum you up as
like the the one guy if not yeah the one
guy who kind of understands how to turn
video games into narratives and to do so
in a way that's fun and effective and
like Pleasant to watch and you're like
oh this is the game that I love you know
among other things and you kind of like
remember you kicked that off back in the
day with the bootleg Universe which is
kind of this this for into it like you
explained it before in the show but like
what would you describe the bootleg
universe as like why why are you
compelled to pursue this
thing like why did I why did I do that
yeah why why did you start the bo
bootleg universe and why have you stuck
with it for so many years what is it
about it well I it was subversive take
subversive but it was subversive takes
on on just things I loved I wanted to I
wanted because I'm selfish Nico that's
why I'm really [__] selfish um I
can't love something without going into
it grabbing it and manipulating it some
way right and that's that's what it was
okay um I mean that's basically what we
were doing on our YouTube channel too
it's like I like Halo I want to do an
action scene in Halo and I'm not going
to let anybody tell me no totally and
this is why this is why we became
friends I'm like oh they're doing what
I'm doing this is great like we should
hang out
um yeah
and and um yeah and I guess captain
laserhawk is now another evolution of
that I wouldn't say it's necessarily
just what you said I don't think it
necessarily just applies to games it's
it's uh cartoons it's anime it's it's
right it's like it's all the culture
that we kind of grew up with it's the
culture we grew up with yeah yeah yeah
yeah and so you just you just dropped a
Netflix series which is Captain laser
Hawk based on Far Cry blood dragon which
is like inspired by inspired by you're
right not based on it's a very deep cut
of a Ubisoft like franchise but the the
series itself is I mean it's hard to
describe it's like it's like the
Multiverse of Ubisoft did you like it I
did I it I could see I could see a lot
of your influence in it plus the fact
that you're also one of the characters
which was a a fun little surprise and I
also look like the
the look
like is hilarious yeah I didn't know you
uh you could do voice acting it was
actually really solid well I'm I'm voice
acting as an American right now so oh
really yeah what's do you have a can
will you drop the veil dude I I do so
many different accents so we've talked
about this before right so I was born in
India MH um uh in Kolkata then we moved
to Madras which is South India Mumbai
which is uh also India but elsewhere now
these are different regions that have
different dialects different accents
different different uh different
cultures then we moved to Hong Kong
which was a uh British colony at the
time right so so I'm going to so so I
literally adopted a British accent to
fit it when did you move to Hong Kong
how old were you five five okay so all
these places you know Mumbai Chennai
Kolkata had the local accent then we
moved to Hong Kong and I had a British
accent I put it on because I'm like okay
this is how people talk so did your
parents speak English to you while you
were growing up or were you speaking
what what language did you start with as
a kid Hindi Hindi yeah Hindi and so
actually my my mom is a Hindi speaker
and uh and that's
Kolkata that's that's that part of India
but when you go to South India chenai
that's where my my father's from it's a
different language it's tamel so my dad
speaks
Tamil so I learned a little bit of Tamil
when I was a when I was very
little so everywhere I was going I was
um completely
morphing my voice to like Mystique from
the [__]
X-Men fit in to the uh the local culture
right and then and then we then I then I
end up going to a German Swiss School H
in Hong Kong and I adopt that
accent so so do you have do you have
have you like have you obtained like a
neutral accent like one that's like
culmination of all them brought
together no no no no no no well again
there's there you know it's so like
wildly desperate and I feel like part of
you is begging me to like start using
different accents no you don't have to
start doing
impressions but uh no no no no I I
because again different accents they use
different parts of the of the voice
right I actually find it harder to
communicate with the American accent do
you do you think with an accent like the
voice in your head does it have any ACC
a great question um it depends
on what I've been using and what I'm
thinking about right mhm I'll give you
an example which is which is interesting
something that just recently happened to
me um last
week I was doing a TV interview for
India um and I was talking in my
American
accent and then I I said look can I just
talk to you in my Indian accent they're
like please I dropped it go into my
Indian accent and the the texture of the
conversation completely shifted it
became different and I wasun it was it
was like a different s part of myself
emerged if that makes sense so it's
like in a weird in a weird way it's
almost
like multiple personalities but again
that's that's too extreme I don't want
to say that but it's almost like that
where um when you use a different accent
a different part of yourself emerges not
too dissimilar from like different
clothes right like if you wear a bandana
like the times you wear a bandana and
feather boa like that's a different Nico
that emerges one they don't see on
YouTube right than than the than the
cigar smoking leather jack jacket um
which is the one that my children see
right totally yeah yeah with the Harley
yeah yeah man I mean language is one of
those things too it's like it's not just
the words it's the rhythms it's the
intonations and all those things you
know the musicality to it and like
different languages just Express like
you think differently when you have
different languages running in your mind
totally yeah totally
did you read you read the book snow
crash right of course yeah I love that
concept that you can program brains
through language and how they learn to
speak like dictates how fast they can
calculate I mean it's super sci-fi like
and out there but like it's a great
premise for a book yeah okay so back to
laser Hawk Captain laser Hawk blood
dragon remix you should all watch it yes
it's on Netflix right now um so you have
the Castlevania series that you worked
on and you have laser Hawk and you know
looking at at Netflix you know there's
other like there's a cyberp punk anime
that's out as well do you feel like
animation is where like video game
stories are going to live as opposed to
like like Last of Us HBO style things or
movies is it is animation now the
realm so I don't feel like there's any
one thing that is like necessarily the
realm just like I don't feel like
there's any one thing that is quote the
right way to do something um I feel like
it's all going to exist um it can all be
done
well um with the caveat
that there's too much content that's
been
made there's too few people watching
that content and the content that is
being watched is getting most of the
eyeballs right yeah and now we have
strikes we have uh uh an economic
meltdown that's happening across
gaming film TV streaming theatrical all
of it there's a [__] meltdown
happening right I've had after laser H
has happened came out you know when when
you have a project come out your your
agent gets like incoming calls people
want to meet you okay that's pretty
normal so fine we set up all these
meetings Okay Addy will meet this guy
and that guy and that guy um and then
like two days before multiple meetings
they're like okay um we actually can't
do this meeting anymore everyone's been
fired oh wow and I'm talking these are
like heads of companies it's not yeah
these are like the president of the
company or a company with a with a with
an overall deal where they're like okay
now the deal has been
pulled so the whole like I guess yeah so
the whole apparatus is is not crumbling
but it is going through an evolution and
because of that
Evolution what gets made going forward
may be different you had an interesting
that like some so there's a lot of
content not enough eyeballs and eyeballs
are there are disproportionately
watching like one thing yes why is that
is that just human nature are we do we
just need one thing that we can kind of
unite under or is it just how content's
being served to people because it's
algorithmic I don't think it's any one
thing yeah but I would I would point to
a few things one um Quality
Control
um has been a moving
[Laughter]
Target right there's been there's been a
lot of
spending and there was an arms race
there was an arms race to to to build
content libraries right and the spending
wasn't necessarily like oh what's the
good idea that needs the money it's more
like what's the idea that's going to
pull all good ideas right they're all
being made by they're all good ideas
they're all good ideas you know um I
realized this a few years ago I'm like
oh it it's no
longer it used be impossible to get
something made in green L mhm so when we
both started out in this business it was
[__] impossible if you got something
made it was
like
crazy um then it Al all of a sudden
became a different context where it
wasn't it it was it wasn't like easy I'm
not going to say it was
easy but things were being just green
lit mhm just just cuz things were just
being greenlit right business was
happening business was happen happening
money was flowing deals were dealing
dealing wheelers were dealing and
dealers were being wheeled whatever the
[__] that means um but uh yeah that that
is over that is just [__] over
because um you know again we said
quality control um I would point also
to the fact
[Applause]
that when we had few distribution
channels you know you you had uh the
three major networks in the you have a
global audience but I'm just going to
focus this on on America just just just
cause you had NBC ABC CBS that made
stuff and then you had H oh that that
made like how would you Des how would
you describe their their content oh NBC
ABC and CBS it was like it was the
classic sitcom comedy it's like how can
we make it a show with like Charming
characters that's like almost entirely
writing takes place in dang living room
and how can we like just make it so
charming and fun that like they also
have like cop shows and procedure you
know they cop shows doctor shows formula
but yeah find a format that you can
reproduce every week that millions of
people want to watch Law and Order yeah
CSI ER and but they feel like little by
little that just they had to keep
turning the quality up you know until
it's your effectively having to produce
mini movies every week for thing right
but still it's it's like those are the
channel and that was it but they they
kind of knew they were programming for
an audience
now my perception at the time when we
were first breaking in was like oh these
they felt like Gatekeepers
MH but now I'm kind
of reexamining that um that belief
structure they were definitely
Gatekeepers they were Gatekeepers for
sure but were they also perhaps like
Arbiters of quality I maybe not even
quality is the right word here but they
knew what the audience wanted and they
were programming for the audience right
right and they were also programming for
commercials well you had that time slot
competition right where it's like it's 9
o' on a Thursday night everybody's in
their house whatever we put on TV needs
to be the best thing on TV otherwise
they're going to watch this thing
instead you don't really have that now
it's like oh this show is literally
fighting this show right you don't have
that so it's all gone right yeah so
which BRS me to another point on all of
this if Sylvester Stallone releases a
movie today on streaming in
theaters
um he's competing against or that movie
is competing against every Stallone
movie that's ever been
produced it's competing with every
Schwarzenegger movie that's ever been
produced right it's competing with every
action movie in America from America
from Korea from India right MH it's not
just competing with what's being
broadcast on ABC at that that day
yeah yeah it's intense so so there's a
fragmentation and just the viewership in
general there too much content which is
I feel like is one of the reasons maybe
the strike took so long to sort out is
it's like we already have so much
content it's like there's not a rush to
start making more
content again I don't think it's it was
I I don't I I don't know it's not one
thing it's not I feel like it's one
thing I feel like we've got you know um
you have these
like
um trying to find someone to blame here
um it's it's the management Consultants
it's like McKenzie and Company Bane and
Company do do you know a lot about these
people I don't want to do a deep deep
dive but effectively they've been kind
of like the
Architects I would argue they've been
like The Architects of a lot of the
chaos that's
happened in
in in America Amica and in the world cuz
their their their whole
um business model
is [__] we shouldn't talk about this
this is this is is this like algorithmic
thought manipulation kind of stuff kind
of but look their their their whole
thing is you know uh uh shell will hire
McKenzie and be like what do we do and
then um Bank of America will hire
they're telling everyone what to do MH
because they're Consultants you they get
paid to consult and they're giving
everyone the same advice which is
downsize scale
like um you know scale at all costs
right so so we we've basically been in
this
world
where how do I even say this he's
like Wall Street and then the companies
that are being financed by Wall Street
are being for fored
to uh have
astronomical profits or
astronomical or or or to prove that they
have astronomical
valuations and that is
unsustainable yeah and that
system is what's crashing and that's not
a that's not a Hollywood thing it's not
a strike thing it's affecting gaming
it's affecting it's affecting the whole
world MH
from specifically an entertainment slice
of things I feel like there do that make
any sense or did I sound like it made
sense [__] nuts it made
sense into it that's the thing I can
deep dive into the [__] Nuance of
that and what what that is right but
that was just kind of like the elevator
pitch yeah we can leave that as like
that's the in appetizer to the
conversation but if you want to find out
more if someone's listening to someone
wants to find out more just just Google
mckenzi and Company it's called McKenzie
and Company just just Google them AOL
keyword mackenan company yeah and and do
a deep dive and you know there's the
propaganda version of what they do and
then there's the the reality of what
they're what they they do and I'm get
and yeah
and it's dark well the thing that I've
I've observed it's like so we have a
bunch of like tech companies in
entertainment now and like entertainment
is a thing where it's always felt like a
huge aspect of the economy like how like
this Marvel film made how many millions
of dollars Avatar made a billion dollars
like we talk about money we talk about
how much movies cost but while they have
this huge cultural impact as far as like
the actual money being generated
compared to like other sectors of the
economy it's just it's not a a big chunk
and I feel like I feel like tech
companies are discovering that right now
as they you know as Netflix tries to
become a huge company based off entirely
just entertainment yeah yeah that could
be WB what what do you
think I mean again I I feel like content
artists have been devalued through all
of
this by calling it content and I'm
calling it content because I'm like kind
of making fun of
it um but you
know uh well how do you how do you
Tarantino is not a content creator you
know what I'm
saying I need more Tarantino content for
my theater to fill my theater minutes
it's like um well that's like the that's
the broadcast thinking where it's like
you have a time frame it's like we need
fill these time slots I don't feel like
it's broadcast as much as it because
because broadcast did a great job of
event tizing their broadcast right they
created the Super Bowl right they
literally created the Super Bowl they
turned it into a thing
um so I don't know if that's broadcast
thinking although I would argue that the
TV people have taken
over the entertainment apparatus and the
the film people have
been
demoted maybe um because at the end of
the day what is the MCU it is a massive
TV show right where you just it's like
what's the point of making one 90-minute
episode of TV when you can make 10
90-minute episodes of TV exactly yeah
and release them in theaters yeah people
follow around okay
so uh what was your question I don't
know we were just going let's keep going
no you asked a great question though and
I feel like I [__] I did the thing
where I you asked a great question you
said man I don't know I mean I I like
this talking like what's happening with
the industry and you know I was talking
about I I don't know if this was the
question I was talking about like the
size of um the size of entertainment in
our perception of it as being part of
like business and the economy like the
reality sure sure so I I don't again I
think Netflix is great I will go out and
say I think Netflix is great Netflix has
been great and Netflix has been great to
me
um so I'm kind of removing them from the
conversation because we're talking about
tech MH so let's just talk about it Tech
ethos yeah like the subscription
platform apps all of it right so
um or even like the apple and Amazon
side okay let's talk about Apple
yeah who made the iPhone Steve well not
Steve Jobs but you have no [__] idea
you have no [__] idea who who made
the who came up with the Vision Pro you
have no [__] idea all you know is
apple right so in a way like this Tech
ethos feels like we're going to get rid
of people we're going to get rid of
superstars mhm and at the end of the day
the brand is the
star yeah right yeah the brand is the
star it doesn't matter who made the
[__]
iPad Apple made the iPad I mean that's
Disney basically right but you see how
that ethos has been co-opted and adopted
by entertainment because yes that is
Disney but that wasn't Disney
historically right yeah you'd have yeah
you have aurs Walt Disney was a [__]
dude who was a star you know what I'm
saying yeah apple was not a dude right
apple is a [__] Apple yeah you know
what I'm saying it's like a logo it's
like right now if you're like you know
who who comes up with the Mickey Mouse
stories these days it's like Disney like
who comes to like you know the the
Marvel series like Disney like so I feel
like the lack of stars or an
unwillingness to Mint
Stars has also
hurt uh the entertainment business and
the the entire ecosystem right because
like the uh and we can expand on that on
every [__] Direction but does that
make sense yeah and do you are you
seeing that Trend also I mean I think
the one thing you mentioned about like
the there's too much content and two
little
eyeballs um you know you can have twoo
little eyeballs and too much content
like that can work if the economics are
set up where you know somebody can
survive off 10,000 20,000 30,000
eyeballs um which is kind of what we're
trying to do with C digital.com you know
where we can have like a small audience
that can really support this stuff
absolutely yeah
absolutely however you have not taken
money from the venture capitalist have
not there's not some hedge fund
breathing down your neck saying okay
Nico listen you're getting 10,000 views
we need you to get a 100 million views
every day so we're going to scale you
and go as big as possible we're going to
sink a lot of money into this and you'll
turn to them and be like dude that
there's no way that's going to work or
be profitable yeah and they'll force you
to do it and then Corridor will be
gone right yeah that is the the story
for a lot
of like tech company or or or startups
yeah it's it's that it's like they take
on the venture capital and you have a
debt that you have to then you're forced
to scale yeah you're forced to scale
because the man management Consultants
sorry yeah it actually I reminds me of
advice I got when I was going to college
which was if you take out college loans
the time after college you want freedom
to try things like to go be an intern
somewhere or work for free for somebody
and if you're paying if you have to pay
off a, do a month in a college loan then
then the first thing that happens when
you get out of college is you go and get
a job yeah and I feel like that's what
happens when you do the venture
capitalist thing and you go into debt
and you take funding is like you've
immediately take on on that debt and now
the first thing you do once you graduate
from college is you have to get a job
you can't experiment you can't try
things you can't have that fre it's that
on steroids because now you're forced to
take on
more capital Y in order to because
because in this it's not oh you have to
get a job it's like look you could get a
job but we don't want you to get a job
we actually want you to get a PhD yeah
and we'll get you that PhD but you have
to do it our way this way and uh it's
going to cost you well it's going to
cost
you all this money and you have to take
it on and you have so it's like they're
telling you how to navigate yeah your
business you're trapped and that's the
only way out exactly yeah you're in a
high-speed [__] car race with a bunch
of other cars that don't want to be in
that race and are all being forced to
and at the end of the at the end of the
day there's no finish line there's a
wall and you're going to all crash into
it
right um like there a big Pacman behind
you that's coming at you at a certain
speed and you have to keep your foot on
the pedal and this model got you know so
what work for Facebook you
know long time ago worked for Amazon so
we all have to yeah you know and and
it's like what are you pushing exactly
like like a monopoly that's what winning
looks like it's a monopoly right because
you were asking me um earlier you're
like oh well there's you know there's
cyber Punk Edge Runners there's Arcane
um Last of Us right
and you were like what direction is it
going to
go and um part two to my answer to that
is I don't feel like I'm in competition
with anybody I don't feel like I need to
win I feel like there's a lot of
customers out there let's call them
customers audience customers
viewers enthusiasts right whatever the
whatever the [__] word is there's a
lot of people out there fans mhm and I
feel like they should all be served
right and um if what I'm providing
is not uh not what you want well then
okay there's and it's too dark great
there's the cuphead show right which is
not dark there's um different options
and I feel like more options is good
for people for the consumer the audience
um yeah so like like this this mind
inste of like having to win and having
to be like the and and defining winning
as everybody else
losing that is some [__] up [__] and
that is the tech
ethos right it's it's we're going to
gobble everyone up up and there will
only be one logo and it'll be an apple
and no one will know anything behind
this or anyone behind this Apple logo
because no one there
matters it's just a brand it's just aand
and everyone will obey the brand
speaking of immortal Brands to what
extent like to what exent to what extent
do you think a company should own an
idea like you know an artist writes a
story the publisher pays them pays them
for the rights now the publisher owns a
story you know if uh for a couple years
10 years 20 years is there a point where
like if your nephew has a birthday cake
with that character on it at what should
that character be part of culture and
belong to everybody where do you where
do you see that
transition so Pard of me wants to just
literally say I am the wrong guy to like
I I'm the wrong guy to even talk about
this but I'm saying that because I've
had like wildly Divergent opinions on
this right like I'm like copyright's
[__] it's not real dude I don't know
at the end of the day I don't know right
because I understand the concept of
things being available to
people and
like and at the same time I also
understand the concept of like someone
needing to own something to incentivize
them to keep doing it right right right
because it def it descends into like
socialism like the bad kind of socialism
where it's like oh I made a game great
[__] you now the state owns the game
right like wait what what happened to
the tetris right right yeah um they're
like great Russia owns this game like
what no no no I just made this game
great well you work for the Russian
people so yeah exactly um
so man I just feel like it's a it's got
to be a
balance uh it's just got to be a balance
I I don't where that line is I I have no
idea
um but
um yeah what I should should Luke sky be
in the public domain by
now I've made you prime prime directive
of the United States you can decide
whatever you
want okay so wait so so I'm not Addie
I'm in charge of the United States yeah
I mean you're still Addie but you're
like supreme ruler but I'm Addie who's
supreme ruler of the United States low
stakes no then I would seize it then I
would seize it for the United States I
would I would pass laws saying that no
this if if if I'm the ruler of the
United States I'd start seizing all the
IP for the United States for the good of
the United States right okay or or well
that's assuming that I'm an evil
ruler oh man I don't [__] know dude
like CU you like we we both started
making
videos and there's a sense of like I
like Halo I'm going to do a short film
with Halo or I like Power Rangers I'm
going to do a short film with Power
Rangers like I grew up on these things
they are part of my identity to a
certain point I have ownership of that
you know it's like yes sure like Bungie
you you own halo Microsoft you own halo
cool but I also own a little bit of Halo
too like the Halo that influenced me and
yeah and and the argument I used to make
back in the day when I was like super
anti-copyright and I actually felt like
it was this evil empire trying to like
[__] impose their will on me that's
gen legitimately how I felt the argument
I would make is like okay I didn't ask
to be born I just showed up mhm and I
didn't ask for American television to be
like [__] beamed to me everywhere in
the world like this like you know what
I'm saying I it just kind of happened to
me you you put this thing this image in
front of my eyeballs and it like it's
now like in my subconscious and now
you're telling me no and you can only
engage with it in this way exactly right
yeah um so that was the argument I used
to make back in the day that like you
know yeah you own it but go [__]
yourself now I've grown up now I've
grown up
uh look I feel like there is no right
and
wrong there is no good and bad
especially with these kind of things
right I think we as a as a
society uh have to
make decisions on
on what to do MH and how these things
should be navigated I think where we get
into trouble is when
one entity or one person or one party or
one interest group has way too much
power right so if Disney can Lobby the
US government can force Senators to
extend copyright law for
like thousands of years
MH okay then right that's an extreme
case right and the Other Extreme is like
the tetris example mhm you made
Tetris but you don't own it yeah and
that doesn't feel right either that
doesn't feel right either that feels
yeah they both feel like robbery yeah
and it's hard because be like well okay
so then you get 40 years plus 10 years
of this like well now you're just arbitr
putting arbitrarily putting like math
and time frames on it I feel like you're
punting something down the road yeah and
the other thing that's like weird about
um things falling into the public domain
is different countries have different
public domain laws mhm right so like um
correct me correct me if I'm wrong but
uh James Bond has fallen into the public
domain in Canada I think this the
literary version has yeah
yeah and then um and then there's a
Nuance with
um the trademark yeah there's a Nuance
with the trademark again I if I'd known
what we were talking about this I would
have like read up I I kind of shed s of
this conversation psychologically
because I'm like I I don't want to
become this like IP cuz it'll just come
and bite me in the ass in the future
right someone like because I I'll like
make something and then someone will do
some weird ripoff of it and I'll be
really mad and someone be like you're a
hypocrite so I just like I'm like okay I
can see the writing on the wall that's
gonna [__] happen to me one day G let
it happen man just gon just just all
right no but um yeah there's a thing you
know with like um so Zoro H like is Zoro
in the public domain like or Sherlock
Holmes but you know the the uh the fam's
EST State can always come back and and
contest it and create issues so yeah you
know again there's a [__] Nuance here
and you're asking me my opinion and my
opinion is I don't have an
opinion um but I feel like we
should have a
collective understanding of what the
rules are and we don't and that's the
problem we don't yeah I part of that
issue is having artists and Company kind
of treated they're separate things but
also they're the same things at the same
time where it's like you have an artist
create a concept but then the company
can own the concept so now the artist no
longer owns it the company owns it but
the person who created it is still
that's an interesting point that's
[__] thank you for bringing that up
dude because that's the other Nuance
here right because so many laws in
America seem to just favor the corporate
entities right they're designed to
protect corporate
interests but in uh in
Europe like in Japan for instance the
the author of the thing has way more
control than they do here right so when
you look at um
like the guys that uh sh Shuster
and the guys the the guys that created
Superman uhhuh if they nearly died you
know they're working as janitors like
when the Superman movie blew up
up they were working as janitors like
that's not fair either right that's not
at that point put Superman into the
[__] public domain dude yeah you know
what I'm saying that's that that that
just feels gross yeah that feels that
feels gross I'm like how am I supposed
to consume this thing knowing
that and look you can make the argument
that Superman had all these different
iterations and what but still there's
just like kind of an unfairness there
you know um
versus yeah know the creators of the
things at least in and I can use Japan
as an example they're just treated with
so much reverence that's cool I think
that's
cool all right does that is that do you
feel complete there we can talk about
this more I mean you're right thing is
like I could go really in on this but I
do have another I do have another topic
I want to talk about two actually I I'd
love to talk about laser Hawk a little
bit more for sure but really it just
leads me to my greater love which is
talking about game movies and video game
TV shows sure because that's you know
that's effectively what it is
um so what's the best in your opinion
what's not the best what what video game
based show or movie stands out to you
what what are like your top three
personally video game best based shows
or
movies okay so I'd say snow
piercer that's not based on a game no
but the visual language was very much
based on true I'm talking about actually
based on game
properties I would see Captain laserhawk
okay you Great Captain laser Hawk number
one Castlevania number
two my upcoming Devil May Cry series
actually number three number one really
number one is number one yep um it's
actually a tie for number one with laser
Hawk and Devil May Cry
okay um all kidding aside
um I don't really I don't have a you
know I don't I don't I don't have a like
a like a winner yeah you know I feel
like it's all great I I generally and
I'm not like trying to so it's not the
original Mortal Kombat film pardon it's
not the original Mortal Kombat film no I
love the original Mortal Kombat film I
love the
that's like that's my number one
honestly but but that's going to change
you know at some point that'll change
right you'll you know you'll have like
did you love the film or did you love
the feeling of playing Mortal Kombat and
then all of a sudden seeing these
characters in a in live action right I
me yeah that's that's what that's but
you're a parent now you're a parent now
one day you're going to share you know
you're you're going to be playing uh I
don't know Metroid with your with your
child and
then what I'm I don't know what I'm
saying I mean yeah definitely you need
the experience like nobody's going to
have the same relationship with the
Mortal Kombat movie now that I had with
it when I was like 10 years old right
because like you need to be having
played Mortal Kombat in your SNES
secretly without your parents seeing it
and then going to see the movie like for
that or Duke nuk right same thing like
you you sneak into the basement and you
play Duke Nukem and everyone in school
is like oh my God Duke nukem's crazy
dude yeah right like yeah like
that was a experience that you only got
in a specific period of time like in a
like that was like our generation yeah
and maybe even a little little bit older
and I mean that's definitely like yeah
so you know for I think like a good
video game movie or TV series like it
needs to be paired with that those those
Universal feelings that people have had
playing that game and if it's you know
it's years and years removed like you
know if you tried to drop a Duke nuk
movie now like who cares
right you're not working on one are
you I didn't hear your feelings did I
I'm not working on
a um
I but you know it's like that
relationship to the game is important
well it depend it depends on how you're
writing the movie right if you're if
you're trying to like have it pull from
like gameplay experience versus like
just characters like those are different
things but I don't know I I bring this
up because I wanted to ask like what you
know you you worked with so many
franchises now at this point what
franchise if we're up to you would you
want to tackle here's an actual answer
to this question your Mario Kart videos
yeah I loved your Mario Kart videos do
you like to see a Mario Kart movie no
but I loved your Mario Kart videos oh as
a as a top list yeah oh well thank you
like literally most of my top stuff if I
were to actually pick top stuff would be
your stuff oh well thanks because
flattering because you know it's it it
it's the
you guys were able to alchemize the
silliness of Game of
Games with um the seriousness of
games like I'm going to butcher it so
I'm not going to try to distill why it's
[__] cool but it's just [__] cool
right like you guys were doing it you
were having fun you weren't trying to
make it anything other than how you saw
it and that's cool it's awesome I
[__] love your stuff thanks I [__]
love your stuff I'm like
genuinely a fan of the of the I don't
want to call it content but I'm gen
genuinely a fan of the content you guys
have made around games oh well you know
your your pubg short oh I love my pubg
pubg Short's [__] sick thank you
um yeah you're
um uh there's and there's one that I was
going to just cite and I'm blanking on
the
[__] name but it's it's where like
almost like Nerf guns are Nerf Team
Fortress Yeah yeah um I loved your
portal your portal stuff in fact you
licensed me or you gave me license you
[__] just gave me some of the footage
from your stuff to using guardians of
Justice because I was like yeah I need
some like yeah so
yeah okay well so if you were working if
you could work on anything right now
like what's what's like a dream video
game or like what's a video game story
what's my dream that I would do right
now yeah I would uh help rebuild
Hollywood actually my dream okay well
before we go into that like from a video
game point of view like what game like
is something that you've always wanted
to
adapt Duke Nukem just
[Laughter]
kidding [__] I I I I don't know because
I'm just
so here's here's the truthful answer and
I hope this does not come up as douchy
so it's probably going to come off as
douchy it it feels like everything is on
the like legitimately on the table for
me which is [__] insane you know what
I'm saying though like everything is on
the table for
meh yeah you've done it multiple times
now and so it's like yeah yeah and like
the biggest stuff is on the table for me
does that does that ruin the magic a
little bit that does that ruin the magic
yeah the fact it's real no I'm like
hyper grateful dude I'm like wow this is
awesome this is crazy that's good that's
good and like you know and and and stuff
was on the table after Castlevania right
then I felt like a kid in the candy
store I'm
like wa all of the what the like how do
I even pick like at that point how do
you pick MH right
um yeah it's like I'm trying to think of
an analogy and I'm just going to think
of a stupid one so I'm not going to um
but but yeah it's like at that point how
do you pick right so then I go okay well
the next one I want to do was um Captain
laser Hawk so why why' you pick Captain
laserhawk is the next
one because I didn't want to adapt one
thing and I wanted to create a new
universe gotcha and I wanted to do like
a an
Orwell Aldis
Huxley um William Gibson
style dystopian story so is that where
it's like and I wanted to effectively
remix
uh a bunch of different characters right
because with Castlevania you're like
okay we're we're like Castlevania was
done like Castlevania was the game at
the end of the day right I was like okay
now's an opportunity to go the opposite
direction not too dissimilar from what
we did with you know Dirty Laundry
Punisher Dirty Laundry the the fan film
where it was like punish was Thomas Jane
playing The Punisher again it's straight
this is the Punisher right and then we
pivot on the other the other side of
that to doing okay what's the opposite
let's do something found footage black
and
white
um like
a documentary about um about this guy
Eddie B who ends up becoming Venom
right so um yeah and this was just kind
of creatively what I felt called to do
at the end of the day none of this was
like a um an intellectually driven
Choice it's just I was super excited
about um this and then Ubisoft was like
absolutely and I'm like wait what so did
you like did you know somebody had
Ubisoft or you just like reach out and
like hey here's an idea I was already
working with them okay I was already
working with them U and that that's you
know that doc it was documented I was
they we had announce some stuff and then
uh and then I handed them this
what was it that made it like how did
you get the absolutely like I'm sure
you've answered this question a million
times in interviews like how did Ubisoft
let you do so many kooky things with the
characters but like how did ubis sof let
you do so many cooky things with the
characters I literally just wrote a
Bible
yeah and the Bible wasn't just the story
it was like the ethos of the story and
it was
like setting clear expectations right up
front yeah it was setting clear
expectations but it was also like a
deconstruction of why I was doing this
this mhm right because in a way you can
look at Captain laserhawk as
this
um alternate timeline I mean it's not
like it's a [__] alternate timeline
right it's said in a world where
automation happened in the 1950s and
then America got sold out to a tech
company so it is an alternate timeline
it is alternate history but another way
of looking at it is is this is what
would have happened had the Templars won
MH
right because Assassin's Creed is
effectively normally set in our world MH
right it's like normally set in our
world it's like oh okay the Abraham
Lincoln and then this happened okay like
so there's
this group fighting this other group and
this has been going on
forever what happens if the Templars
went what does that look
like um that's another way of looking at
it but I wanted just layers you know it
wasn't just one thing so it becomes like
a hard thing to describe when you're
like okay yeah and then you know
rayman's gonna have this this uh you
know he's gonna end up with with tommy
guns and uh he's actually the mouthpiece
for the fascist dyst dystopian uh agenda
and you've got this board of director
two episodes in like wait is Rayman
really like the propagandist for for the
CEOs like that's it was all in the pitch
it was just all in the pitch and it was
outlined and but but there was like a
logic behind it you know um
I
think one of the things I've grown into
and maybe I always did this I I I would
love your opinion on this because you
you've known me um
forever there's
a there's like a shock value to
everything I do kind of like shocking
it's like whoa wait what Batman's what
yeah Superman did what like or the Power
Rangers or what like they're they're
they're child soldiers what but but but
it's not just for shock value there's
also like a like
a a thought process behind it right so
there's there's there's some deeper
theme or some deeper con concept or
construct that I'm trying to explore or
understand um
and
um yeah Captain laserhawk gave me the
opportunity to do
that so so it for me it wasn't just
hey I get all this Ubisoft intellectual
property it wasn't just that but it was
also this this universe this story this
construct this exploration of um Chaos
versus order pardon and meta narrative
too and then and then the IP adds The
Meta
narrative yeah right makes sense yeah
the IP adds The Meta narrative because
it it loses the impact if the chief
propaganda officer
is some original character character
right not just some but an original
character right so the other comp I
threw out a lot was Who Framed Roger
Rabbit you know that was an original
universe but you see Mickey Mouse there
you see Bugs Bunny there these these
these beloved characters uh are
populating this
universe yeah I mean I like that because
I think it also you know it it pulls up
this concept of like your relationship
with fictional beings and like who's to
say you can't just have the any story be
a story with these fictional characters
right we all try to pretend that like
well if you kill Batman he's dead it's
like well not really you know so or what
is Batman I mean he's like
um I mean the character's been
reinvented every every right decade or
so which goes back to our question of
should Batman be owned by a company
anymore too if he's just a
representation
of evil man you know not evil man but
like dark Justice man yeah so
um yeah it so when you you know you
approach Ubisoft I'm assuming you sit
down with some higher ups in a meeting
and you're like here's the idea here's
the concept and you're just upfront with
it right off the bat and it was all in
the pitch Bible dude the whole thing was
in the pitch Bible and they're just like
all right yeah let's go yeah yeah um so
that's pretty cool you know Ubisoft is
owned and controlled by uh six brothers
Six Brothers really yeah so it's it's
it's an interesting company and I really
um can't stress how much I loved working
with the folks at ubis we worked with
them bunch in the past yeah you did the
Assassin's Creed Assassin's Creed we did
a we did like a 40 minute long um
division like narrative thing yeah done
a whole bunch like they were letting us
do that they were letting us do
effectively official fan films and
funding them long before anybody else
was so Ubisoft is like ahead of the
curve with that kind of thing yeah
that's pretty crazy okay so right before
I asked you about this this video game
stuff you said your real dream is
rebuilding
Hollywood yeah because I feel like you
know um I was in an industry
MH that operated by some
rules and not everyone agreed with those
rules but those were the rules and those
had been the rules
since long before I was [__] born or
you were
born and then all of a sudden Tech came
in it's the it's the Apple thing where
we're talking about earlier right
there's only Apple there are no
stars you're not going to know who made
this device it's a collective it's a
collective it's Apple you're all
replaceable you're all cogs in a machine
and
that
ethos among many other ethoses that that
that work for other businesses do not
work for entertainment penetrated my
industry case in point by getting rid of
stars the only Stars left are stars from
the 90s right right like Nick Cage is a
bigger deal today than he was in 1997
right right Will Smith can do and and
just have chaos happening in his
personal life [__] that would have made
him like a director radio name in
1997 and he still will [__] Smith
because there is no one else to right
replace him right because now all of a
sudden the guys in the
90s are like last ones stand it because
they're the only ones that are hit you
know they're broadcast everybody on like
you know major networks when there was
no other channels and so it's the only
thing that we the machine from back in
the day got behind them so there was
there was lots of money spent making
sure that you know who Brad Pit is you
know who Tom Cruz is you know who Bruce
Willis is Right MH
so yeah so so it's like the apparatus
but can you even make Stars anymore yeah
for sure even with such a fractured
audience space and you know distribution
there's always been fractured audiences
there's always been things to distract
you
but when I entered the
business and you I was in the
[__] so like 2008 2009 was when I
started and I really things really
picked up four years later
[Music]
but Hollywood was culturally
dominant the movie
studios um were culturally
dominant and that wasn't by luck that
didn't just happen that was by
designh and things have happened over
the last um you know decade decade
plus that have um hurt
that and we can get into what those
things are you know it's the we've been
rocked by
scandals so so the like the perception
of the the the the illusion of Glamour
is gone
mhm um that's one example of it
uh [__] I mean I can just like rattle
off 30 examples of things that have that
have hurt
um have hurt us I'm saying us because
I'm like now as it's slipping away I'm
all of a sudden like whoa whoa whoa whoa
ex I had a foot in the YouTube thing and
in this online thing and the Hollywood
thing but now I'm like no
like that's where I got my start like
that's like I want that back MH part of
it's like selfishness right I like used
to get treated like really
well went out you know what I mean yeah
I was like treated really well uh and
now we're all content
creators it is weird seeing movie
posters effectively just another
thumbnail in a row of thumbnails yeah
which is scary cuz like it's like you're
an icon within an app yeah it's like how
do you stand out now can you stand out
now you can stand out now you can but
it's again investing in Stars mhm
because here's how I look at it the
business people [__]
up the business people
lost they just [__] up and they lost
and you know you can blame McKenzie you
can blame the banks you can blame Wall
Street you can
blame coid and the street people getting
drunk on the streaming Wars overspending
all you you can you can blame blame
blame blame blame it and there's a lot
of blame to go around but at the end of
the day the business people were driving
the ship they had a vision for what
Hollywood was going to be which was
content content content content all day
long we're going to drown you in content
and like that's just not how people
behave right this isn't [__] wall
dude this is not Wall-E like your vision
for Global dominance was
Wall-E what the [__] yeah you know what
I'm saying so you do it through Stars
right like um
I'm trying to give you a concrete
example to illustrate what I'm saying
and but yeah I mean Hollywood was built
off the back of stardom like yeah you
know there was there
was but yeah Hollywood was built off the
back to start yeah and look maybe the
Stars aren't famous faces
anymore so right but like James
Cameron's a star yeah right like there's
like what the [__] Chris Nolan Chris
Nolan's a
star G Del Toro is a
star right so there's they're not
content
creators or maybe they are I don't
know's I'm old fashioned there's brand
strength in the artists so to speak you
know when you know you're going to see
feel that's you can distill it down into
business terms by saying there's you
know they have brand Equity with the
audience fine they
do but there's also an innate like
Talent there
right right so like there's an innate
Talent there with with the with the you
know when you say you know the business
people lost are you effec saying that
like they're overproduced there's too
much content I'm saying the business
people [__] up they had a vision for
where to guide the ship
MH and they they they lost in the
um when I say they lost I mean they had
a vision for where to guide the ship and
they were guiding the ship that
direction that's just off a cliff that
direction is off a [__] cliff MH and
the cliff has been all the things we've
been talking about in this podcast right
people not really watching people not
caring Hollywood no longer being this
like dominant cultural cultural [__]
Force um uh in the culture uh art
becoming content so much content that it
devalues the content and then devalues
the artist um you know I'm going to draw
a parallel to video games here because a
lot of video games I feel like are kind
of doing the same thing where it's they
get you to keep playing a video game not
because it's fun and you like it but
because they're basically employing
psychological tricks you know a little
trickle of updates here some things you
have to do here a little grind here you
get a reward Etc and you know I I I'm
I've been playing Call of Duty a bunch
this year and on one hand the game's
super fun but on the other hand it's
like I'm I'm playing Call of Duty still
like I was playing that game in college
why why is it still Call of Duty why is
there not a new video game out and it's
like well it's because it's the same
game with all these little BS added to
it to it's the business people doing
that yeah so you're not you're not
inventing new games you're not coming
out you're just rescanning the same game
and adding your little because because
going hey we're gonna find the next 10
James Camerons and we're going to
develop them we're going to cultivate
them that's very hard that that's not I
don't think that's hard i' actually
think I don't think that's hard I think
I think I think when someone has talent
it's kind of obvious and how to and to
to to develop the talent I know how I I
know I I can do that I can do that I
know how to do that can give someone a
blueprint on do that and I would argue
you know how to do that because you
actually do do that here at cordor digit
I think to me the hard part is creating
the environment around with which you
can do that and justify it and make it
happen Okay but if you are running the
business apparatus that is designed to
find them and cultivate them you will do
that like the uh the the Hollywood
Studios back in in the day that's
literally what they did right they had a
bunch of talent they identified the
stars and then they said okay we are
going to elevate you to a [__] level
where the general public is going to be
salivating over you but don't let it get
to your head like that's what they
[__] did
right um but the problem
is that
is hard to model
out so instead they take the approach of
franchise ability mhm it's the the MCU
thing they take the MCU approach well no
we don't need Stars we going have Brands
Brands going to be the star right
intellectual property people are going
to show up it's it's the it's honestly
it's the Heim sabon Power Rangers thing
right no one cares about you they care
about the power ranger helmet right and
we're going to keep recycling the helmet
with different faces but people will
care about Power
Rangers and they'll care
about you know care they'll care about
the logo not the people who play the
characters and that is a business
philosophy it is a and I and look that
works for some people it works for some
consumers it works on some
consumers like you're saying Call of
Duty right they're releasing a Call of
Duty every year or two every year or
every [__] yeah I mean it's just one
machine that's it's you know effectively
a live service game a machine that's
constantly updated with little with
stuff in right um
but what we're seeing now is that
doesn't work because the audience wison
up to it in real time yeah or at least
you can't at least in the video game
Space it's you can't start a new one so
to speak it's like well let me just spin
up my new firstperson shooter and
Implement all this stuff and it's like
well no it's not Call of Duty anymore
but so yeah I mean games and movies have
gone through the same thing so if you
look at uh movies they used to program
for America right you'd have like a
you'd have a screw ball comedy then
you'd have a gangster movie then you'd
have a family movie you'd have a musical
you had all these types of movies all
these genres because the people that ran
the movie studios went we want to
program for
everyone you know we'll have you'll have
a few options every weekend and we'll
program for everybody well now people
don't go to the movie every weekend fine
but also most of your options are $200
million IP driven you know it's Wall-E
yeah it's literally w-e dude honestly I
feel like the business people [__]
sat down and watched Wall-E and went huh
we should bring this you know this is
this is
great but it's it's Wall-E you know it's
like hey we're gonna do Indiana
Jones 12 and we're going to do Star
Wars every year like Duty yeah right
we're exactly and it's it's that but you
know where does that come from because
dude up until recently
Artists movie people the [__]
Executives they hated sequels no one
wanted to do sequels I mean you remember
that right sequels were awful because no
one wanted to do them yeah it like
literally doing a sequel was a kiss of
death in you know back in the day I'm
saying back in the day we didn't do
sequel Hollywood didn't you can expect
to make half the revenue and half
thought the audience didn't want to see
it they're like I've seen this already
and and look and a lot of times those
sequels were bad right you had some
examples that were um you had Terminator
2 and Empire Strikes Back and you know
occasionally a sequel had pop but yeah
you're right yeah I mean look but then
Terminator 2 You could argue is really
just a I mean yeah sure there's there
there's the Canon of in there Canon but
Terminator 2 was just a remake of
Terminator 1 right and Terminator 3
would be the true sequel right and
Terminator 1 was a lowbudget horror
horror Indie movie and Terminator 2 was
you know now Cameron has some clout so
he's like okay I want to remake my old
movie but just call Terminator 2 yeah
with you know uh knock more resources
yeah he knocked that [__] thing out
of the park right because he's James
Cameron yeah but they also developed
James
Cameron right they like went this guy
has an interesting
voice well let's develop him let's pair
him up with producers and actors and
artists and yeah yeah yeah um and and
there was systems in place to guide
people's careers
mhm now I've studied this stuff because
I'm
a
I again I'm not from this country so
going to Hollywood was like this
impossible thing I'm like whoa like what
is Hollywood this is crazy right and you
hear like people rapping about Hollywood
and their songs about Hollywood I'm like
I want to know what the [__] this is
right so so I studied the history of
Hollywood
mhm and the different iterations of it
and the different Nations and I was I
was saying that as a preamble to a point
I'm about to make but I forgot why I was
saying that but I studied
Hollywood and oh it's just the
point
um the lack of career
development or the career guidance
m
institutionally is
shocking so you don't have another
generation coming in to like pick it up
I mean dude I think you're a talented
filmmaker right and again we're we're
the same
age and I don't view myself as like on a
pedestal over you so so it's not that
obviously we're friends
too but when we first met and you were
like hey I want to do movies right M I
sat down with you and I was like hey
this is the ways you can do it this is
how you can develop your career if this
is the thing you want to go I did that
right yeah um
did anyone else do that for you not
really okay but you had a you had agents
courting you you had managers courting
you where the [__] were they yeah right
why is it that um you're a talented
dude why is it that the only person
that's giving you advice on how to
navigate the apparatus that governs what
gets made and how to how to have a role
within it how why is it that the only
person giving you advice is someone your
own age
that's a flaw on the system that's a
flaw on the system right where's the
Elder going you you you you know and I
can look back at that era now and go
clearly like and like a lot of the names
are like signed on that wall right
like yeah there were there were talented
filmmakers that emerged from YouTube
yeah 100% who stayed on YouTube
because
the
machine didn't show up and when the
machine showed up it wasn't to cultivate
you it was like to to to to have you
[__] shoot an infomercial for Dwayne
Johnson Yeah well yeah I mean
like back in that Journey like you know
like you said you know I wanted to make
a film do an action film do a sci-fi
film any of that kind of thing you know
everybody has their strengths and their
limitations right and like I'm not a
script writer I I can write but it's
like a slow and painful process and I
can take a script and think about how
I'd shoot it but just let me sit down
and bang out a script on the typewriter
like that's hard for me to do and I feel
like if there's more of that apparatus
you're talking about it would be more of
a thing to bring these people together
and bring their talents together but
there are so many screenwriters who are
talented who have like read their
material and giving them like feedback
and it's just my personal feedback right
and then they'll like thank me they'll
like you're the first person to give me
constructive criticism I'm like what the
[__] dude you have like an agent and a
manager and a [__] like how is no one
reading your material right so and again
it sounds like I it feels like I'm
complaining and again these things
haven't affected me they've actually
helped me right the fact that that most
of the people in our industry have been
asleep with the wheel has actually
helped me because I know how to navigate
on my own right so I I'm like all right
I'm gonna get the rights there I'm G to
talk to this person I'm gonna get
the by the way I've navigated all of
this without an agent or a manager or a
lawyer in some
instances like I just go in I do the
deal
just talk to people cuz I'm like dude
once I add
layers again I have an agent now it's
great he's great um and yeah and I've
been working with with um some managers
and stuff and I'm I'm going to build out
a team because I but now I'm like
clearly in a place
where uh I can lead MH my team so when I
bring you on to my team I'm like not
like telling you what to do because it's
not it's not that but like I have a
Clear Vision as to where I want to
be um in five
years and how I want to get there and
how I want to get there and I don't mean
like I want to do this project and that
project I mean like with the kind of um
the
ethos the um and how I want to show up
right like like if I don't want to work
with Shady people that that's what I
mean yeah like so I'm not going to um
sacrifice my
Integrity yeah that that kind of thing
which should be a given but I want to
just voice that out loud because I said
how I want to get there I meant like oh
I want to do this brand and then that no
but um but again you know all of this
complaining I'm doing on the behalf of
all of my
peers Ubisoft actually did this for
me mhm how so
uh there's a dude a gentleman named Hugo
Ron
in Ubisoft motion picture uh Filman
Television right he randomly called me
up he got my number he called me up and
he said hey we love your
stuff would you like to work with us and
I'm like uh yeah so he offered me a
property he said okay so you know we
have a deal
here to do something with this property
do you want to work with us I'm like
yeah sure great that sounds great they
brought me into the fold right M and um
when I first started working with them
it wasn't clear in what context I would
be working with them right because is it
like am I a
consultant am I a a producer am I
someone to help them package their uh IP
to shop it to networks right like
because I could have it could have gone
all these different ways right and the
thing is they never boxed me
in they never boxed me in right because
I could have very easily been the guy
that um was like okay so this is how we
get this IP made and we do that and I
you know I worked with this writer on
this movie um we bring him in and and
like basically put packages together and
taken them
out and that is a road and nothing
against that road but that is a road I
could have taken right but then but then
I'm like no I actually feel my highest
[__] excitement is to do Captain
laserhawk but that's to me Career
Development it's it's giving people
options it's working with them so so
yeah Hugo brought me into the family um
and uh there's a lovely executive at
Ubisoft named
helain helain has been with Ubisoft for
a
while and um she's she's super lovely
just super supportive and um yeah I had
the same conversation with Hela right
it's like what do you want to do um here
are some options and um it it evolved
into me creating this new brand for
them it literally evolved
organically
but you know and then as I was even
doing it and pitching it like like and
and as I was pitching it to the
different networks obviously Netflix
ended up winning the the bidding for it
but you know you know we uh um Gerard
who's one of the brothers he came with
uh with I'm butchering the [__] story
I'm sorry um but uh Gerard came with me
and helain and Hugo to every pitch
meeting and Gerard early on again Gerard
is the the head of Ubisoft film and TV
and he's one of the brothers
that that uh that owns
Ubisoft or controls it rather um
so he early on was like he read the
Bible and he Saidi love this we want you
to make this we're going to make this
with you and we're going to clear the
path for you to make this right so sign
off right from the top
yeah he came to every pitch meeting
because again like you're you're there
talking to [__] insert blank guy that
owns a network who's
like I'm basically telling them like I'm
going to have Mickey Mouse doing drugs
and they're like there's no [__] way
dude and then they're like and he's like
and D was like no no no no we this is
this is our characters but this is
bootleg Universe he literally kept
saying that this is our characters but
this is bootleg
Universe
um that's one example of a plethora of
examples of how I was just supported
through this process and I don't mean
like support as like oh everything I
said was was like they said yes to it's
not that's not
support support is also push back
support is also um giving you alternate
ideas support is also Hugo calling me up
and saying hey dude um you have to meet
these Folks At Bobby pills ended up
being our Animation Studio they are
[__] great and they are your
people and I had like one phone call
with them I'm like yeah these these
people are awesome
but you know they they they
found the perfect
collaborators for
me also you know for them but for me
right because it it would be so easy to
be like okay um here's this Animation
Studio we've worked with before they've
done the rabids cartoons you have to use
them right or hey we have this company
that we've invested in you got to use
that but no they like literally went how
do we
support this Vision you
have that's I mean yeah that's not a
frequent occurrence that's a that's a
rare thing to have somebody like like
let's do this and let's make it good
right yeah right but that's the
energy that that is going to [__]
bring Hollywood back from the [__]
ashes right that energy right it's going
to take Executives to [__] show
up show up and do your [__] job it's
going to take agents to show show up and
be like look you don't need to represent
[__] 2,000 people on your [__]
roster mhm right find the 20 you believe
in and show up yeah and work for them
and work for them and [__] show up
yeah it's going to take lawyers to not
take six months to close a deal that
should take an
hour right yeah the apparatus that is
Hollywood is so bloated and broken from
this
[__] that and again none of this affects
me this all benefits me right because
I'll go in and do I'll close my own deal
yeah I'm like you done it before so you
know what to do I know what to do I have
all the templates I know I've like
studied this [__] yeah um
but yeah like it's it's going to take
you know sorry so our business is
bloated right and there's going to be
Mass
layoffs there I mean there already are
mass layoffs yeah they going to be
more and uh it's kind of like
Survivor or like a weird reality show or
whatever but like the people that are
left
standing it's then and I hope I'm one of
them by the way I'm not assuming I don't
want to assume like I may be I may be on
the [__] life raft right like working
working for Nico getting him coffee um
but you know the the the people that are
left it's then on them to [__]
acknowledge that the system is broken
that the machine has been tarnished and
taint tainted and feathered tarred and
[__] feathered in front of the whole
world and go dude how do we get it back
to being a culturally dominant [__]
machine well let me let me ask you a
perhaps a question that we can kind of
use as a theme
for our way out of this podcast so we're
talking about Hollywood and fixing
Hollywood but like you know we talked
about a lot when we first met about
trying to just make it in the the first
place somebody who's wanting to make
movies narratives TV shows doesn't
really matter but somebody who's not
trying to do like hey I'm GNA just Vlog
into the camera somebody's like hey I
want to write a script and I want to
tell a story with my
cinematography how did they get started
these
days honestly you are the
better resource for that well yeah but
I'm on the YouTube side but you're
you're in the actual like industry how
do you I would argue because of
everything that I'm saying that I've
been ranting and raving about like a
[__] lunatic about how people need to
show up and do their [__] jobs in the
way that Ubisoft
did yeah right um because again there's
the
like it's it's funny because people send
me like memes online where um there was
this
like there was like really this really
funny like chain where someone was like
how the [__] did this show get green lit
and and the response was Addie it's Addy
Shankar he he does this and he's now too
powerful to be stopped like they acting
like I'm this dark lord that's running
around and like it was this so funny I
want to someone said this to me and I'm
like I'm G to frame this this is
hilarious I'm like like [__]
saon like you know um this is what he
does and he's now too powerful to stop
right but that's not true like it took
everybody
at um Ubisoft to show up it took
everyone at Bobby pills to show up and
it took all of our Executives at Netflix
to show
up and um this is why I'm actually in
animation dude it's it's not because I
love animation don't get me wrong I love
animation but my Executives that I work
with at Netflix I love them I literally
love them if Netflix were to cut them
tomorrow I would hire them I would
literally hire them tomorrow yeah and
the only reason reason I'm not hiring
them right now is because I'm like okay
well I work with you at Netflix and I
like you know the people matter the
people are everything the logos obvious
the logo means [__] all yeah so if
somebody's starting out if somebody's
trying to get into it so show up meet
people people matter no no but sorry the
the thing I'm ranting and raving about
is because of how the
last seven to you know whatever X number
of years have gone
you know you're saying oh well I'm in
the YouTube space and you're in the in
the in the real
space I would argue there's no
separation right now yeah there's no
separation you know uh a hit is a hit a
hit is a hit yeah it's it's all apps in
a row on your screen a hit is a [__]
hit dude so if you're um Mr beast making
a video
that that is effectively like a a a a CB
s game show and I don't want to be I
don't mean to be reductive and I'm not
trying to be like but I mean it is it's
a game show he's making CBS game shows
and he's doing it you know he's he's a
production company that does that that's
[__] great how is that product any
different
from the reality shows that are being
produced by the by the real it's not
it's just yeah it's just another video
on the internet another video on the
internet which I fallen into the habit
of calling every single thing a video
now right because they are they're all
videos on the internet some are behind
you know different like like like Halo
is a video on the internet there you
have a Halo Paramount plus has a Halo
everyone has Halo videos on the internet
right yeah whatever so I don't think
there's a differentiation and actually I
think the lack of differentiation is
actually the problem yeah that's the
problem right and that's not getting
solved overnight so I don't know what
the solution is or how sorry I do know
what the solution is I don't know how
it'll manifest or if this you know
that'll come together mhm but for now
what you do and what I do is not
different just make stuff we just make
stuff right yeah um and I would argue
that some of the stuff you
make is
more impactful I'm not talking about
views yeah you get a lot of views but I
I think the whole view economy is also
kind of [__] up right because then
you're basically saying well porn
pornography actually gets the most views
so the biggest influencers are you know
so all these metrics are little whacka
dooodle do and also uh let's be honest a
lot of the views on the internet are
fake a lot of the [__] follower
accounts on social media are [__]
and uh I think there's going to be a not
I think there's going to be a reckoning
it's already happened where brands are
like
investing lots of money because oh it's
like you get a lot more engagement a lot
more
exposure from Instagram or Facebook than
you do for buying a TV spot only to find
out but none of these convert right are
these real people or are these [__]
Bots yeah and the answer is it's a
little bit of both yeah it's like the
emotional engagement is like what
matters like a little off topic here but
you yeah you your stuff right it
resonates it resonates it just [__]
resonates right I I show people your
videos um to be like hey you want to see
something cool this is cool you know
um like as an example you know one of
the things that I loved about Hitchcock
I don't know if I loved this about
Hitchcock but it was an observation I
made about
Hitchcock because he was there when film
was evolving so rapidly so he would
discover like a trick or a or a or a
storytelling kind
of thing thing and then he would make a
whole movie around it right so like rear
window rear window is a perfect example
of this you do the same thing you do the
same thing like your like your top down
shooter video MH yeah it's like here's
an idea okay what story does it unlock
we're gonna use a we can use a drone how
are we going to use this drone to tell
right yeah um like you and Freddy long I
think we doing correct me if I'm wrong
I'm not well-versed in Internet history
like I'm in Hollywood history but uh you
guys were doing FPS videos
before before movies were doing it yeah
before movies were doing it there was
that seen in the original Doom movie
that had first person shooter stuff but
yes that was very janky compared to how
we were doing it by the way the SAG
strike is now officially over oh really
yeah I just got a text it's officially
over all right so the rebuilding of
Hollywood begins
tomorrow they heard this podcast and
they're like all right we got to get
this done boys this guy is right we
[__] up we are so sorry um huh yeah
maybe we shouldn't have bet the farm on
whatever the [__] we bet the farm on
yeah and look I don't want to bmer the
business people but I'm bising the
[__] business people right
um my executive at Netflix are [__]
great my Executives at Netflix are
[__]
great like um I was telling a my friend
will rename remain
nameless but he's he's a friend I love
him dearly but he says things to me and
then I have to be like
bro if I listen to what you just said I
would not be in a good
place but I was telling him like last
year um you know we're working on I was
working on devil M cry and I'm like God
you know like they just give me the best
notes H they just give me the best notes
and I keep asking them for more notes
I'm like can you give me more
notes because wow that's a rarity to
hear I want to keep getting notes I'm
like keep giving me not like how much
time do we have cuz I I've you know I've
worked on this script
for a long [__] time like a long long
long [__] time mhm cuz I wanted to
get better and better and better and
better me and Alex Larsson who my
collaborator
on definitely correct and I just want
more and more notes and they kept giving
me more notes and they kept making the
thing better I was telling my friend
that and he's like dude you can't open
the door to that bro like they'll then
they'll take over your show I'm like no
they're not taking over the show dude
they are they are here with me producing
the show with me and working every day
with me to make this thing awesome right
which is amazing when you can find
people like that because it's like
you're supporting each other yes yes and
it's also on you as the [__] artist
or it's me on me as the creator of the
show to show up in a way that creates
that environment
MH yeah cuz if I bring my if I bring a
bunch of [__] and I'm like oh my God
they're trying it's my vision and
they're trying to take it from me it's
like no right then it's going to create
an adversarial relationship here I'm
like recognizing that they're helping me
they're seeing things that I'm not
seeing because I'm too deep in
it yeah right yeah and um but again
that's a thing that an agent or a
manager needs to tell a young artist MH
otherwise you there's so many artists
and some of them on the wall that I'm
not going to name names maybe I could
name names in a cough as a joke um you
know to really besched Mike Diva's name
out loud but like have not received any
[__]
guidance right Mike is classic example
of a guy received no guidance I'm so
glad he's now on SNL because I'm like
you are in a machine and this is going
to make you level up yeah he yeah he's
leveled up mentally just from his two
years being there yeah yeah but again
that's an example of what I'm talking
about right because uh SNL is SNL
because Lauren Michaels Lauren Michaels
there's one dude that kind of
is
the I'm I'm not advocating for like one
dude to be in charge of everything
that's not what I'm saying but I think
you you were going to illustrate my
point better than I thought yeah I was
just going to say like it's a like
that's a guy that
building that machine and bringing
people in and like you know Mike got
brought in you know but Mike got brought
in but Lauren Michaels is also very old
now and there isn't a new Lauren
Michaels no because then it becomes
because the machine hasn't progressed to
its next Generation like saying yes yes
totally yeah it's
um yeah it's great you were asking me a
question about
um do I feel like a made it not made it
like yeah okay yes yes so all right here
we'll we'll we'll wrap up the podcast
with this question all right
so we talked about making video game
movies and video game TV shows we talked
about how you know it's been our vision
had like you know we as we were growing
up it wasn't really done right and then
finally boom you are you know with
Netflix making shows based on these
games with with the people that make the
games and you my question was do you
feel like you are finally doing what you
want to do do you feel like you are
finally getting to make these pieces
that you had Visions for getting into
film I guess my follow-up question is
how is that different from what I've
been
doing like like and that's actually a
real question like is is laser Hawk
something like fundamentally different
than what I've been doing I
would here's the thing so this you make
you make this question complicated
because you made gods and secrets which
I feel like is a dis Justice sorry
guardians of Justice sorry old latent
memories sitting in my brain horrible
memories ni will you please give me some
fck also also I'm so [__] can you please
shoot this open her for me in a Sho
string
budet I'll be right there Addie don't
worry uh so you know you made Guardians
of justice and to me a Guardians of
Justice was this culmination of like
your your bootleg Universe concept you
know I I want to take these ideas these
things that inspired me and shaped my
vision of entertainment and media I want
to be able to make it and like you had
to do it bootleg and then now you don't
have to do it bootleg you're just doing
it with the actual owners of the IPS you
know does that does that feel like does
that feel like you're still in the
bootleg universe is that is that what
you wanted the bootleg Universe to
become have you reached reached this
goal of being able to finally make the
pieces that are I guess but you're right
you've already done it you've already
made pieces that touch upon and
acknowledge these cultural influences in
yourself but I'm also evolving every
year as a as a human being and as a
person right um like like this year has
been in a lot of ways the worst year of
my life and I'm not going to get into
that but you know
why
uh just other than I I think we could
say
I I'm lucky to be alive M we'll just
leave it that I'm lucky to be
alive um but actually through the
adversity though that's kind of the gift
there's gift through I've I've grown
through this this
amazing um adversity and I've showed up
I I've i' I've become a leveled up
version of myself through this like
crazy
adversity that I've
um experienced and really had the
privilege of experiencing let's put it
that way right because what doesn't kill
you makes you [__] stronger
um
so but you know there sorry go well you
know like so take your Punisher short
for example like there is a difference
between the Punisher short and captain
laserhawk now you know Captain laser
Hawk feels like such a deeper
realization of these this you know de
foray into like what's influenced you
and like but it's also where I'm at now
mhm right so it's not like I'm getting
clo it's not like I wanted to do Captain
laser hog
in 2012 and no one let me m The Punisher
short and again Punisher short did that
with Phil xanu who is uh taught me so
much he was one of my earliest mentors
phano directed that short he was one of
my earliest mentors uh Thomas Jane
obviously started Tom ended up being a
mentor to me right because I'd like
because he he called me up one day he's
like hey pal you know
uh I think you should really focus on
this YouTube thing I'm like okay I'll do
that yeah yeah I feel like it's a you do
that a little bit and you know it'll
unlock some doors along the way like
wise words from Thomas [__] Jane and
the guy's brilliant he really I'm he's
brilliant but it wasn't like when we
were doing the Punisher short what I
actually wanted to be doing was a uh it
was a short about a an Assassin's Creed
frog right but right if the Punisher
short could have been a Punisher series
then you could have just done it would
you have no no that that dude that was
literally on the table so um Eric
barmack who uh was an executive at
Netflix left a couple years ago um but
he was an early executive at Netflix
early early like we're talking they like
they're just getting into making
original
content he dm'd me after the uh Punisher
short came out and we had conversations
I had conversation with Eric barmack
he's like hey what are you doing with
this you know that this is a series uh
TV networks were hey like again Thomas
Jane he's a great actor he's also a star
he's a big [__] name yeah and
especially in TV he was coming off of a
show called hung on HBO so HBO wanted to
be in business with Tom
uh and uh Chad St John who ultimately
wrote the script for that was a was an
in demand writer h so yeah we had an
opportunity to make that into a series H
we
didn't why
not because then it cheapens
it because what was cool about it was we
would sit around drink cans or not
bottles of Mexican Coke it's the the
coke Mexican Coke that's what it's
called sugar in it yeah Coke we would
sit there in my office drink it Tom
would talk about working out
out and then we came up with this thing
then we made
it and we just made it there was no
contracts there was no it was all
handshake deals people just showed up it
was fun it was it was it was how I
imagined film making should be and it's
probably kind of how it is for you yeah
that's how I imagine it should be too
and that's how I try to keep it right
because it's really easy to have it not
I mean it usually isn't that no so it
was a lot of [__] fun and the only
time suits showed up and I suits I mean
like agents and
[__] Tom mentioned like well after the
fact like we'd already made it it was in
post it was done it was like they were
ready to drop it and he mentioned it to
his
agent and an army of Agents it felt it
felt like you know in Captain laserhawk
episode two where the where you've got
the tiger dudes in the suits yeah and
they're like you know it felt like that
they all went they all like [__]
piled in they're all in my office I had
a conference room they're like sitting
there and they're watching it and and uh
they're like where did this come from
how did again they didn't understand
digital film making this was back in the
this is uh 2012 so this was back in
the is it for a TV network is it for a
movie is this independent they didn't
know how to classify it and they're in
there and and they're like Tom where did
this come from and then he just like
points at me he's like yeah this kid did
it and they're all like all the suits
look at me and I'm
like right and
um and then
they leave and I'm like Tom I feel like
such a [__] impostor dude like I I'm
like literally I was like literally just
in college like I was literally just in
college and now I have like movies
coming out and I got like what the [__]
and he's like hey pal you know
what here's a secret I feel like an
imposter
too and then he goes to and then Phil
xanu was in the room and he's like Phil
you feel like an impostor and Phil was
like yeah yeah no you always and then
they're like explained to me that the
impostor thing is like part of the
creative Spirit of like um staying young
it's like staying young right because
the suits that walked in that day those
agents none of them had impostor
syndrome
MH yeah they also lack
self-awareness right
um but yeah like uh yeah it was it was
sorry I just turned that dark and I
besched the suit the suits they were
very very nice they were like this is
great look it's what you sign up for
when you put a suit on like you're just
you're going to be and they left and
they all Scurry out and I'm like what
the [__] was that it was like a wave
right and like one of the dudes like um
was like Angelina Jolie's agent and he's
like and he like looks at me after
because Tom's like oh it was all him and
then I'm like then he's like we need to
get you in the room with
Angelina and I'm like joliee like what
the [__] is happening like uh okay um
yeah and then you know and then
yeah and he a bunch of people Amber herd
and then I got to you know I met Amber
and Amber herd uh sent me a book she was
like you're really into science fiction
you should uh read this book that I
think you should make I'm going to send
you a copies then she mails me a copy
with Like A really lovely note
um again only nice things to say this
about Amber herd here um the book was
the handmaid taale
H she literally sent me the handmaid
tail she's like I think you should make
this veryy [__] right dude I should
have listened to ammer her um but why
did I talk about that um so we made the
Punisher thing that is what I wanted to
do at that moment in
time so you didn't want to make a
Punisher series you wanted to make your
own Punisher thing and that's all it
need to be got it yes that's what we
were talking about yes so but then the
moment it became hey let's make this
into a Series
M
then it became the suits and the
contracts and the lawyers and how are we
going to do this and who's going to
create the show and who's going to do
the thing and then Addie you know what
what uh how do you want to do this and
I'm like here's what I want to actually
do I love
Tom I'm going to get way more enjoyment
in my life by having Phil xanu as my
[__] mentor and he's going to teach
me all these things that I will have
never learned in the film school that I
never got to go to right and um I want
to take this
experience and have it be like
a cherished
memory vers it it being like molested by
the [__]
Hollywood deal making [__] you know
what I mean yeah um so yeah I just you
know made another one with uh the the
with Venom mhm and I'm like we just do
another one yep that's what I at the uh
we were at the comic maima man yep
Machinima Machinima [__] Machinima
yeah and
um and I'm like no I'm just gonna do
another one I'm gonna do another one I'm
gonna do another one and I I
like yeah there's like a part of me that
really is a business dude in a way
because I have that in me right I have
that in me like I like I know the moves
you've called me before and I've told
you what the business moves are right
yeah and I do this for friends of mine
they're like hey what what are my next
moves and I'm like you do this you do
that you do this you do that I cannot do
this myself because the the part of me
that knows the chess moves is in
conflict with the part of me that wants
to [__] do the opposite of what I'm
supposed to
do but yeah the the business move would
have been to do a Punisher TV not a
Punisher a dirty laundry TV series right
and
um and yeah like would it have been a
you know would Marvel have who [__]
cares maybe I don't know like I know the
Marvel people watched it because I was
in a theater with Kevin fige as he was
[__] watching it uh you know what I
mean this is a true story and
Fabro like I'm sitting in a theater with
feige and Fabro sitting next to Tom here
pearlman's there Phil's there and I'm
like fy's there oh they're playing it it
was a it was a North Hollywood it's a
whole other story I don't want to get
into that but like no it didn't need to
be anything more
than what it was and in a way what
I'm does this make sense or am I a
[__] idiot that you just you made it
for what it was that was it look I kind
of I asked this all started with the
question like if you want to make it to
this day and age and you're just
starting out how do you get into it and
part of the reason I ask that is because
you know we talk about making movies
here at Corridor making shows things
like that and we have we've made movies
and we've made TV shows but like they've
never been like a Hollywood film it's
never been a theatrical film right and
going into next year I want to do more
movies right I we have things that we've
written and it's kind of at this thing
where it's like I just got to shoot it
and make it and let it be something I
can live on the website or the YouTube
channel and anything beyond that is just
like it it starts to take it out of that
realm of this is what I want to do or
this is what like what makes movies
enjoyable and why I want to do them and
turns it too much into that business
move you know
so it's it's interesting hearing about
like why you mention and the business
moves and let me said you just unlocked
something for me the business moves have
a [__] problem in that the business
moves have a very specific way that they
move and every culture's business moves
are different right so when you're doing
business with Japan which I've done
right I literally flew to Japan and did
business I don't need to my own horn
here sorry it's me being douchy but I've
I've I've done business in
America um Across America by the way
it's different in different states uh in
Korea and Japan and
India I and and the business moves are
different the business etiquette is
different the pace of it is
different but the one unifying thing is
because the business people have been so
dominant
um they expect the artist unless the
artist has leverage which I would argue
I have leverage which is why I'm able to
kind of Bend bend the reality to my will
a little bit a little bit not like the
dark lord like that tweet twitter guys
just a little bit a little dark
Apprentice but the business people are
trying to go okay this is how it has to
be
done you have to fight against that
um I have to no me just saying when they
say if you're trying to do it a certain
way and they say it has to be done this
way it ends up being something you have
to fight against you don't have to fight
against it you could just do way the
problem you have MH is your way works
for you now right and your way has been
battle tested to work for you MH that's
not everyone's case if you're a young
filmmaker out there that's not your
situation listen to the business guy
right your situation is
your way has been battle tested so you
got to get the business people to bend
to you otherwise you're gonna end up
doing like another [__] infomercial
for Dwayne The Rock
Johnson yeah they'll be like Nico you
have to wait in this room for 25 minutes
and Dwayne will come in and do that and
then leave I'm kidding that was a joke I
don't it's cool Sam was when who had to
wait in the room I wasn't there I didn't
get to
go Sam's a waiting in the room type
anyway so it's all good um
but
um but yeah I mean I guess that's what
I've been telling you since we met
actually well yeah I mean that and I
think that's just the reality that I've
like tried to accept is that like if I'm
going to do it my way I have to do it my
way like you can't do it your way then
ask some business guy to come that
doesn't mean do it alone no it doesn't
mean do it alone but it does it does
limit the scope right if you're not
going to go limit Partners you can have
which is both good and bad right because
because if you're like hey it's got to
be like
this it just means that like we have to
very much focus on it being doable
because there's we're not quite in the
you know in the full future yet where
just any movie Can Be Imagined in your
head like you still have to shoot it and
that's gotten cheaper and easier but
still not at the point where it's just
like I can just snap my fingers and but
you need support and also like you know
there's a there's a point you made on um
remember where it was a podcast or
something which I thought was brilliant
which is movies they spend a lot per
minute so you have a big big crew yeah
that are just sitting around just
sitting around if you have to figure
something out right in the event you
have to figure something out so there
there there is an insurance policy
M you don't need that for your YouTube
stuff right right because you're not
burning hundreds of thousands a minute
yeah it's like if if if I have a project
that needs us to be able to sit around
and set and like figure something out
it's like well then don't build don't
build your production in a way that
makes that cost prohibitive you know
build it so you can actually do that and
take a time should we wrap it up there
yeah let's do it should we I can keep
[__] going I love talking to you this
could be like a Andrew Tate style have
the
cig no we we should wrap it up we're
we're at the end here but we are yeah um
yeah yeah it's
just so I will wrap it up by
saying it's been really great having you
as a friend oh well that's a great what
a great note to end on it's been great
having you as a friend too but I think I
mean since the audience you know isn't
sitting here right between us to expand
it it's it's been it's been cool talking
again because we've been on this journey
as like two guys making it into the
industry from kind of two different
angles but yet from the same point of
view you in many ways yeah and I always
love getting together and sitting down
with you and talking in a podcast I mean
we'll have conversations like this
outside of podcast too but when we get
to do it in a podcast like to hear the
perspectives the insights the the mental
manipulations of like what's going on
it's always it's always fascinating and
like and now we're sitting down and
you're somebody who's had you know
multiple series under your belt you've
worked with some amazing people and some
amazing teams and to hear you still talk
about like
I don't know what's going to happen next
and it's a big question mark in some
ways and in other ways it isn't it's
just it's perhaps what am I'm trying to
say it's it's perhaps reassuring in its
uncertainness to know that everybody has
impostor syndrome makes you feel less
like an impostor you know if you don't
have impostor syndrome you're like high
yeah like you're kind of full of it
right because there there is there's
always something to learn you're always
going to be wrong you got to learn yeah
it's it's kind of like we're ation meets
opportunity um it's like kind of that in
between Zone and between confidence and
fear yeah you know it's it's embracing
the the
discomfort it's knowing that being
confident in what you know but being
open
to having it be challenged um you know I
just feel like that's ultimately
like art is
truth and that is the truth of The Human
Experience we're always evolving
so if you're not sitting in that you're
GNA make [__] right you're GNA make
[__] because then you're
fundamentally existing in a framework
that you are ideologically tied to
through propaganda or your own own brand
of
scoping uh but that made no [__]
sense what no it makes sense does it
make sense yeah if you want to have if
you want to have impact you need to like
you need to investigate things that
matter to people from an emotional life
experience like point of view and that's
always changing and the way you do
that's always changing so if you don't
change if you're not evolving then
you're just stuck doing the same thing
over and over from that emotional truth
point of view you're not offering
anything new but change is scary change
requires you to do new things which
means you're not going to be an expert
which means that imposter syndrome kicks
in again so yeah putting yourself in
situations where you're you feel perhaps
a little bit inadequately prepared is a
sign that you are actually doing
something new yeah it's like it's like
growing it's like growing yeah all right
that's it so long everybody thanks for
listening SL tuning in and uh Andy
thanks so much for for joining us go
check out Captain laser Hawk laser Hawk
blood dragon remix uh it's on Netflix
right now uh this podcast didn't sell
you on it U I'm G to try to sell you on
it right now it's
um it's three different things so one is
it's all of your favorite Ubisoft
intellectual properties Assassin's Creed
Far Cry Splinter Cell Rayman and the
Raving Rabbids The Crew Etc all remixed
and reinterpreted and
reimagined um then second part of the
sales pitches then they're put into this
dystopian
fascist satirical State um called Eden
which is a nod and omod and O om and
owed a deconstruction of George Orwell
or uh Neuromancer or Al this
Huxley finally it's a love
story yeah
um there's nothing else quite like it
there's nothing else quite like it it's
very unique yeah and it's um and it's
said in a world but just this may help
kind of the viewers get it it's set in a
world where and I'll give you the
background of the world so
and and we don't do like the um the uh
the we don't do the thing where we're
like hyper fixated on like lore so we
just put you right into it but here's
the lore um in this world America
develops Automation in the
1950s it's not automation as we know it
today it's automation it's like Iron
Giant style automation MH and
unemployment just skyrockets
so the company that the biggest tech
company of the time called
Eden introduces Universal basic
income and then people are like whoa
what the [__] this is awesome yay and
everything's everything's great and then
Eden goes okay well everyone gets this
many credits but if you spend it in Eden
stores they're worth double and
everyone's like whoa that's awesome so
overnight Eden becomes the
economy uh overnight America stops being
called America and they just call it
Eden
and then they start social control
they're like look uh if you do X Y andz
you get extra credits by the way if you
don't watch this TV show you get doct
credits and then um you know there's no
labor force so they genetically engineer
a hybrid race race of hybrids Animal
Human hybrids
to uh be the labor force for specific
tasks yeah and then you find out that
hey actually automation wasn't fully
real like they had it they kind of had
it but then they were also using
prisoners putting prisoners in these VR
prisons
to be Uber drivers
effectively like so yeah that's the
that's the sales pitch it's pretty cool
it's it's got a lot of like it's got a
lot of really interesting cool ideas so
um yes yeah all right heck yeah
um I love you dude I love you too like
we're going to look back when we're very
old and this is going to be very
meaningful each one is not this podcast
I mean this relationship oh yes I mean
this podcast too why not this podcast
to yeah yeah sweet man well so long
everybody